[Music]
stanford is a leader in
leadership education the black leaders
program is a program that's designed to
give
up and coming black leaders and also
people who've already been quite
successful in their career
the opportunity to engage with people
who have shared experiences
to think about what it means to be a
black leader
[Music]
[Applause]
my goal is to expand the way people see
the world so they have
more options available to them this
program for me is
an opportunity to try to do that an
opportunity to
give people some insight give them
access to each other
in a way that expands the world for them
the people who will benefit the most are
the people who
already think about the role of race in
their
professional life people who are trying
to make sense
of that or trying to succeed whether
in the face of what they perceive to be
or what likely are
barriers it's people who want a
community
of people who have shared experiences
how do we give people who are talented
opportunity to contribute to their full
ability
how do we change the way people
understand the world we live in
stanford's approach to leadership
focuses on how to be
the most successful version of yourself
and then letting
success of the organization flow from
that
for me to be in a room with the kind of
people who would be participating in
this program
is incredibly meaningful and something
that i'm looking forward to